bonjour tout le monde avant impôts
je m'appelle geoffrey j'ai 25 ans et
fils étudiant le craf de voie noble
je suis en général il y sentons licence
iii a pas activité physique adaptée
donc c'est pour la régulation pour la
réhabilitation pour d'une activité
physique adaptée pour des personnes
handicapées ou atteintes de maladies
chroniques
donc si je suis ici aujourd'hui c'est
ensuite la rencontre avec marylène et on
a passé notre bénéfice un ensemble et
voilà les là bas c'est la présentatrice
à elle attendue par les dunes l'histoire
et l'art ou une envie que je vienne ici
la partager le coût donc pour vous
parler d'une histoire à vous raconter
mon parcours je vais commencer à
l'obtention de mon bac j'ai eu en 2011
suite à l'obtention de mon bac je ne
sais pas quoi faire alors que les
enseignants disent clairement
choisissez bien votre orientation car
c'est important de se lever le matin et
d'avoir envie d'aller au boulot moi je
ne savais pas exactement ce que je
voulais faire donc je me suis lancé dans
le théâtre
pour ça je vis d'alarmant pendant un an
j allais roman de suivre une expérience
de théâtre une école toute hâte pour moi
ensuite j'ai intégré une école
professionnelle à lyon et c'est
justement un demande mon arrivée à lyon
que j'ai eus intérieur externe voiture
je me suis endormi devant le volant et
la voiture est allée s'encastrer sur un
nombre de maisons donc à partir de là
les pompiers sont arrivés le samu ont
désincarcéré la voiture et m'ont
directement amenée au chu chu de
grenoble m'emmener dans ce qu'ils
appellent déchocage c'est les urgences
vitales pour des pour les personnes qui
avaient subi un accident telles que g
donc à partir de là plusieurs médecins
ou chirurgiens où on tournait autour de
moi pour réparer toutes les différentes
une lésion que mon accident avait causé
sur mon corps des mains pas que je suis
entré dans le coma dans lequel je suis
resté deux semaines trois joueurs de
renom comme a rejoint existants il avait
décidé à la baie c'est donc un accident
vasculaire cérébral c'est à dire que
j'aime et un caillot de sang qui était
remonté le meneur serbe qui avait bloqué
les laissons regarder mon cerveau vous
êtes invités à poser ensuite à mon
réveil une équipe qui disparaît c'est à
dire que la moitié droite de mon corps
ne fonctionne
le premier diagnostic des lésions que
j'aimerai toujours présente et c'était
un polytraumatisme plusieurs
traumatismes donc fracture l'excitation
et cetera et cetera il ya un traumatisme
crânien grave nous d'après lui physique
j'avais énormément de fracture
j'avais des vexations nouveau la
clavicule ou du poignet le poignet qui
broie makiadi alignait il est et il
n'était plus aligné avec mon bras et
pédaler pilote de la voiture aussi
pendant l'incident ont littéralement
broyé les pieds bon j'ai réalisé qu'il
avait retrouvé la purée l'audio celui du
gauche donc pour pour réparer ça ils
m'ont privé de passage vers gaza
ils ont gâté gosses ils ont constitué à
l'os pour le remettre dans le pied c'est
fou les progrès de la médecine
aujourd'hui mont jolienne disait si tu
avais fait l'accident cinq ans
auparavant
on dit on trouvait certainement coupé le
pied
j'aurais peut-être pu être amputé d'un
point de vue cognitif un traumatisme
craeynest un choc grave au niveau de la
tête donc s'acharner plusieurs visions
donc j'ai fait une aphasie de broca ce
qu'on appelle
on avait lui brocardé pendant une année
avant le cerveau qui s'occupe de notre
langage j'avais pas de souci dans la
compréhension avec les autres ce qui me
disaient mais j'avais un souci avec les
mots que je devais dire bien un film qui
va sortir sur surtout justement une
personne qui a fait un blessé et qu'il
ya eu des problèmes de langage il est
sorti je crois hier je me souviens plus
du nom de la coupe d'asie de leur droit
à notre temps plein un autre pressé
annaba donc j'avais jamais j'avais des
soucis en beau pour faire une caricature
de mon traumatisme que j'ai eu c'est
comme sur la baie une grande dame war de
notre cerveau avec patinoire dans tous
ses tiroirs sans manger au mou lorsque
louis et michel et bien vous tirez
pontiffroy elle vous appelez sim au soir
du crime aux chaises et bien moi pendant
évidente les hiroire succédé au père
clémot se sont inversés se sont mélangés
donc voilà donc il a vu que je remette
tous les maux en place dans mon tiroir
donc ça c'est vrai que j'ai fait pendant
tout foot nist à une manoeuvre aux
psychologues également avec ma famille
qui venait me voir tous les jours au
quotidien et qui venait me soutenir dans
cette épreuve
il me forçait absolument à retrouver moi
même si je trouve moi même si vous aussi
pendant pendant une période d'un mois ou
deux mois à peu près j'étais à l'ozone
musique donc la nausée notice est un
malade qui n'a pas conscience de sa
maladie
c'est dire que j'avais pas compter que
les ferrari c'est en voiture que j'avais
absolument besoin de de conscientiser ça
pour pouvoir nous battre
ensuite pour pouvoir achever les lésions
que cet accident devait poser dans le
traumatisme crânien j'ai aussi également
une perte de mémoire
donc la part de moi rétrograde donc
c'est toutes les choses qu'on me disait
c'est pas et la mémoire artero grade
fonctions mobiles passées j'ai été
dirigé dans une clinique de vérification
avenue du visible dans le dépistage
fille noire dans laquelle je suis resté
huit mois donc ma rééducation elle était
très a été très longue
mais avant ça elle était incertaine
c'est à dire qu'il ne savait pas si
j'avais mauvais billets mon coma il ne
sait pas non plus comment je vous mets
récupérer toutes mes différentes
pathologies donc là quand vous voyez ma
récupération est incroyable miraculeuse
s'attaque au pouvoir je n'en prends pas
parti en fin de cycle j'ose le dire avec
la taille de mon hospitalisation mais ça
me disait de faire une année de pause de
me remettre de toutes ces pathologies de
tous ces traitements que j'avais subi
pendant ma période de rééducation
et c'est à partir de là que j'ai vu mon
premier choix mon premier choix de vie
pour moi farine et pause c'était pas
c'est parce qu'elle est ma portée du
bénéfice
c'est pas ce qui ce qui était plus
important pour moi c'était de continuer
d'aller me confronter à 7 à cette
société a dédié sa mort parce que
lorsqu'on sort d'un accident lorsqu'on
sort une hospitalisation en sort avec un
handicap
est ce que je dis c'est que dans la
société rien n'avait changé pourtant
tout avait changé les gens avaient
changé il n'avait pas tout changer lisez
moi qui avait changé donc jamais changé
mon regard jamais changé mais j'ai
changé je vais m'acheter une heure on
regarde ma vision sur la tête simplement
donc pour à une activité était et est
synonyme d'isolement d'une dépression
s'était ouverte unitaire ou au final on
se retrouve à à à
voulait sans cesse les mêmes pensées
c'est quelque chose qui était absolument
exacte
donc je voulais absolument être actif
dans ma vie retourner patrick tu veux
retourner faire du sport ou retourner
rencontrer les gens vont retourner
discuter à la gueule c'est comme ça que
je vais aussi j'ai pu analyser les
premiers que j'avais avec les gens dans
les changes et que j'ai pu m'en sortir
et donc pour ça je suis retourné dans
mes études de théâtre que jamais entamé
l pour moi continuer le théâtre c d être
en lien avec mon corps quand on est sur
scène quand on quand on se retrouve à
devoir bouger sur scène on se retrouve
on va faire des mouvements on doit
bouger les articulations et à partir de
là je voyais les soucis que je pouvais
avoir au niveau de mon corps qu'est ce
qui me restait un travail est également
le théâtre m'a permis de recouper de
retrouver les mots de retravailler les
mots que j'avais perdu pour ne période
de rééducation
ça m'a permis de retrouver
l'articulation de retravailler mon
éloquence et ça m'a également permis de
retravailler mon mémoire en apprenant
les textes de théâtre mais pour moi le
théâtre ce n'est plus vraiment une
chance que je voulais faire entre une
profession futur le monde de la santé
tellement qu'on ignore quand on n'y met
pas les pieds moi j'allais sauter les
deux pieds joints dans l'affectif
je m'étais retrouvé du jour n'a
hospitalisé j'avais découvert ce monde
de la santé
et j'ai eu envie de travailler pour ça
de travailler pour aider autrui
pourraient aider les autres grâce à
aussi à ce mec tu as qui m'est arrivé
donc je me suis inscrit en première
année de médecine an passé mais je
remarque c'est que c'était pas encore
l'étape où je devais reprendre des
études
j'étais encore beaucoup trop dans la
réplication j'ai continué à faire du
sport je continue je continue à aller
voir l'utilisent thérapeute et je
remarque que plus j'avais travaillé à la
bibliothèque universitaire de huitième
et plus j'ai fait des démos j'avais
besoin d'écrire des lots d'écrire des
mots des textes des phrases et
aujourd'hui c'est un livre qui démarre
chaque match tu t'es pour vivre et qui
est sorti chez les éditions bleu clair
donc c'est un livre que j'ai pu écrire
trois ans après ma sortie
d'hospitalisation et c'est une immense
fierté
surtout quand on sait d'où je reviens
donc voilà celui j'ai écrit aussi dans
l'espoir de transmettre aux autres
d'abord c'est un besoin
c'était pour moi c'était la propre
thérapie que je m'accorde st le fait
d'avoir envie d'extérioriser se passer
si traumatisme qu'il était arrivé mais
j'avais aussi envie de transmettre de
l'espoir vous transmettent que moi
j'avais compris ce que moi j'ai vu
conscientiser dans ma rééducation
donc je raconte ma réplication du jour
de militants à ma sortie
d'hospitalisation donc pour entamer les
800 débat j'ai fait le métier
et ensuite
donc là je suis à un moment j'avais
rendez vous avec les mutins et mon chiot
j celui qui m'a opéré le pied j'avais
rendez vous avec lui je suis allé voir
avec des radios de mon pied est mon
chirurgien avait dit tu as de l'arthrose
d'accord mais ça veut dire quoi villard
est ce que ça veut dire que je dois
arrêter de faire du sport vous aimons
pied c'est quelque chose qui a été
complètement reconstitué les eaux du
bassin et des orteils qui sont à
retrouver cette énergie qui ne bougent
plus jeune est partagé par tous et
toutes la fétuque l'amplitude
articulaire de mon pied non plus
l'affection des distensions c'est une
cause de douleurs quotidiennes
ce pied me fait mal de l'arthrose neuf
tous les jours donc il m'a dit bah
écoutes je ferais si tu continues à
faire du sport il est possible qu'à 27
ans tu te retrouves adore chez heineken
oui il est possible qu'on qu'on doive
refaire une intervention chirurgicale
sur celui ci
c'était mon médecin et je savais à quel
point l'idée était forte pour moi nous
avons fait le pied mon pied y encore est
encore accrochée à moi et c'est un très
bon état un très bon chirurgien
j'aurais pu l'écouter il faut il faut
goûter son médecin mais le métal j'avais
compris aussi que le méta c'est celui
qui est là pour t'informer pour te
prévenir pour te dire les crises qui que
tu en cours
donc ce que j'ai choisi ces deux fibres
mon instinct de faire du sport de
continuer à appuyer sur la douleur
appuyé à pied appuyé jusqu'à voire très
mal mais jamais allé au delà de ce que
je ressentais donc dès que je sentais
que la douleur était vraiment trop trop
trop insupportable et je sentais pas de
mon instinct mes sensations
quand je voulais arrêter j'ai arrêté
mais il fallait que j'ai fait je voulais
avoir mal de pouvoir progresser
je sentais que l'europe va être
bénéfique aux habitants je me suis
inscrit en stage donc là où je suis
aujourd'hui en staps sport études
on continue à faire du sport pour plus
tard outil de travail dans la sarthe et
à travers le sport parce que j'ai
compris que le sport c'est vraiment
important pour la santé et pour la
réducation aussi pour ma rééducation en
tout cas c'est ce qui m'a permis de
progresser de pouvoir a déjà devant vous
aujourd'hui pourra parler comme ça donc
l'inscription en classe ça et pendant
les étés pas vous donner tout ça en
étudiant on a cherché des bleus
étudiants vous connaissez la financière
le problème finances étudiants de
chercher un travail en tant que caissier
par exemple en tant que
personne n'est un bureau à toute la
journée à 6 non moi je suis allé voir
restaurant et je lui dis bonjour je
m'appelle geoffrey gdf thf été achevée
en reconnaissant ce travail et
handicapés mais j'aimerais bien de
famille est avec vous en tant que
certains c'est un snack en bord de plage
ont été parfaits en plus le soleil pour
la page et et donc du coup les patrons
m'ont pris ou embaucher ils ont l'un des
montants le montant travail donc moi je
travaille le matin je savais qu'à fait
je suivais quelques petits coups bas les
gg des tables et je faisais le service
du matin le service du midi et après
j'ai tout n'allait pas au delà voilà
j'ai je me suis forcé à faire ça parce
que je savais que en continuant à
marcher ça me permet de progresser
et là je vais vous parler d'un de la
douleur un métier qui lisait un petit
vous dire lorsque tu avales tu arrêtes
donc ça c'est la théorie du la douleur
est un signal d'alarmé que le borgne
fait pour me prévenir ainsi ne faut pas
aller au delà des 10 heures moi j'avais
une autre théorie
moi j'ai abordé la douleur d'une autre
manière pour moi la douleur s'était tu
as mal à 100 voilà donc c'est ici qu'il
faut travailler et c'est comme ça que
j'ai été dans ma rééducation
j'appuie sur cette douleur jl sud y
affiche sur city et j'appuie sur cette
hausse pour moi le fait de marché
continue à marcher donc de ferme servers
interdite par j'avais appris que l'os se
nourrit de compression décompression
ça me permettait heureux de consolider
vos également ça allait me permettre
d'aller me faire quitter musculature de
mes jambes parce que j'ai eu une grosse
faiblesse musculaire au niveau des gens
donc ça va aussi fermiers de pouvoir
gagner en muscle au niveau des membres
inférieurs
pour revenir au sujet de la conférence
le choix de vie jésus tant une question
à vous tous
voit donc moi pour ma situation ne veut
pas dire que j'ai choisi de faire cet
accident
donc là on est amené à des péripéties
constante dans la vie qui nous amène au
final devoir faire un choix est-ce qu'on
se laisse soumettre par cette situation
est ce qu'on sait et se manger par email
ou est-ce qu'on se bat on décide de se
battre et d'aller au-delà de cette
situation aujourd'hui le pas encore dit
mon handicap
aujourd'hui je parle plutôt de ses
candidats font ce que je lis mal à
apparaître de handicap parce que c'est
pas du tout ce qu'ils deviennent des
besoins primaires et à manger
la toilette mais c'est pas une gêne
discale
s'il ya une chose qu'il faut pas mettre
de côté des douleurs musculaires ont
quotidiennement
[Musique]
voilà aujourd'hui j'ai 25 ans je marche
quoi avec une canne et comme de tous ses
jambes par un petit bout de chemin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]